[Music]
john is with us john's in tampa hi john
how are you
good sir how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
so i have my wife in the background
listening she works at mortgages i'm
prior marine corps veteran we recently
sold our property that we owned and we
stood to gain
175 thousand dollars from the property
we own another house
and our goal is to be debt-free we
follow we follow your principles we both
go to church and we have about a hundred
uh about 120 000 dollars in the property
and 18 000 car payment
today when i finish work i'll be going
to pay off that car
our question uh collaboratively is
do we do a recast and put
fifty thousand
sixty thousand down on the house and pay
it off in a year
or did we go out and pay it off outright
our savings we have about thirty
thousand dollars in savings so
just sort of wanted to hear your
perspective so if you pay it off
outright how much is left in savings
there's about thirty five thousand
dollars you wouldn't have to touch that
um no okay as a whole as a whole there
be okay so why would you not just pay
off your house in your car today
our biggest worries is that if we're in
a if we if we find ourselves
in a recession or a a housing market
uh issue we wanted to have money to
potentially go and buy a house on a
cheap potentially a a not refinance what
do you call them a foreclosure
would you want to hear your perspective
so you would not pay off your house in
order to maybe buy a foreclosure if the
housing market tanks
that that's our idea or our idea is to
have you know have that amount of money
set aside okay i would tell you
regardless of inflation and regardless
of recession
that your best goal your best process
is to never buy a rental property except
with cash and to never do that until
your personal residence is paid for
and so that that set of principles that
i've used in my life and for millions of
other people would lead me to pay off
your house and your car today
so pay off pay off the house if it
wasn't a rental property it was a
secondary it was a secondary i would be
debt free before i wrote any checks to
buy rental property and i would only pay
cash for rental property then so the
point being we're going to pay off this
other property we're going to pay off
your house your house you're going to
pay off your car you're going to be 100
debt free and have 35 000 left in the
bank you've got all of your income now
to start saving to buy a foreclosure
when the housing market goes down
someday i don't know when it's going to
go down
uh not soon enough to change this answer
okay so
what you're saying is give you a call
back in a month and scream on the year
that we're debt free there you go
brother or next week if you want because
or tomorrow if you want but yeah because
you're debt-free pay off everything
that's what i would do listen
something's
the uh the worry the angst that you have
around the economy you're watching the
news too much number one you turn the
channel off but number two
uh the worry and the it's real but
there's no sense in just bathing in the
blood every night the blood of the
newscast and so uh uh
uh
you know the angst that i hear what what
you're what you don't see coming
is that when you pay off all of this
stuff
you're gonna get peace yes
and you don't even realize that that's
there so
because a hundred percent we've done
detailed research 100 of the
foreclosures occur on the home of the
mortgage